es ist 12 uhr willkommen meine damen und
herren hier bei phoenix im studio in der
mitte des tages wenn wir keine
europäische währung hätten dann müssten
wir sie erfinden das sagte kein
geringerer als der deutsche
finanzminister wolfgang schäuble auf dem
wirtschaftsforum der zeit und zwar im
gespräch mit einem politiker der an der
einigung europas und einer europäischen
wirtschaftsgemeinschaft gearbeitet hatte
wie kaum ein anderer jedoch kamen die
schaffung einer gemeinsamen währung erst
nach seiner amtszeit auf den
verhandlungstisch helmut schmidt der
ehemalige bundeskanzler
das ist der zweite im bunde und die
beiden politiker beschäftigen sich mit
der euro-schuldenkrise und mit der
einigung der staatengemeinschaft
die euro krise scheint vorbei zu sein
seit vorigem sommer zum beispiel
spanische kurzläufer also zwei jahres
bonds liegen bei derzeit drei prozent
die zehnjahres bonds sind auf unter 7
griff und auf unter 7 gefallen
die panik der märkte ist vorbei zinsen
gut alles gut
erscheinen wird ist aber nicht
wir
haben wir eine reihe von
substantiellen problemen wir sind auf
dem weg die probleme
schrittweise zu lösen aber wir haben auf
der anderen seite
eine
schwächere entwicklung der
weltwirtschaft der weltwirtschaft
insgesamt das schlägt auch auf die
fähigkeiten die euro-krise zu bewältigen
oder weiter voran zu führen ein stück
weit durch
wir haben einen gewissen
vertrauensvorschuss
in den märkten oder ein gewisses
vertrauen zurück gewonnen aber das ist
fragil das hat auch mit der mit
ankündigungen der ezb ein stück weit zu
tun wir müssen liefern
schritt um schritt im augenblick ist
griechenland dabei will sie haben die
umstände gestern abend heute nacht
verfolgt
wir sind nicht griechenland nicht überm
berg ich fürchte dass wir am in der
kommenden woche noch nicht zu denn zu
den ich sehe jedenfalls im augenblick
noch nicht über die entscheide man schon
da kommenden woche zustande bringen
hülsen hinkriege mann und mit
griechenland und deswegen es wäre zu
früh in warmen zu gehen ich glaube wir
können das schaffen wir sind auf dem
richtigen weg aber dass sie nicht über
den berg aber
griechische langläufer sind von
36 auf 18 gefallen ist doch toll oder
naja
die lösung in griechenland ist ein
bisschen kompliziert und mit deinem
respekt das war ja ich habe nicht gesagt
das ist eine simple lösung ist ich sage
nur großer fortschritt helmut schmidt
ist die krise vorbei oder nicht
ist überhaupt nicht vorbei
wir sind mittendrin in einer
staatsschuldenkrise wir sind außerdem
mitten in einer weltrezession
und wir sind dabei
statt eines klaren sieges die methode
des modeling crew des durchwurschtelns
anzuwenden wir werden noch zwei drei
jahre weiterhin und durchwurschteln
scheibe durch vorstellen das geht und
sie sind sie ein durchwurschteln ich mit
allem respekt ich meine mich an einen
früheren bundeskanzler zu erinnern und
finanznöte der diese methode als
regierungs methode erklärt hat wenn ich
und insofern in der tat ein stück ja ein
stück weit wir wissen die richtung aber
wir müssen die einzelnen entscheidungen
müssen wir immer ein stück weit auf
sicht fahren und das kann man marketings
wohnen jedenfalls hat es früher mal ein
aus hamburg stammender bundeskanzler so
genannt also da haben wir ja keine so
schlechten historischen beispiel
wie hat diese hamburger bundeskanzlers
genannt durchwursteln marketings die
würde ich niemals durch rost und sagen
aber es ist dieselbe
helmut schmidt sie beklagen heute was
sie früher selber gemacht haben also
modeling so wie der kollege
finanzminister hier sagt es stimmt das
haben sie dann auch durchgemacht oder
war das einfach damals eine völlig
andere zeit mandl links so klingt
jedenfalls besser als durch wurden
und mindestens ist das in hamburg so
aber natürlich haben wir in den 70er
jahren uns durchgewurschtelt
andererseits
waren die äußeren umstände in den 70er
jahren völlig anders
zum beispiel
war der außenhandels anteil am deutschen
bruttosozialprodukt halb so groß wie
heute
china spielt hier überhaupt keine rolle
indien spiele eine ganz kleine rolle die
entscheidenden
volkswirtschaften waren die amerikaner
die japaner und die europäischen ist
inzwischen haben wir erlebt dass
im laufe des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
die weltbevölkerung
sich vervierfacht hat
zu meinen lebzeiten eine vervierfachung
der weltbevölkerung und die leute
brauchen alle was zu essen infolgedessen
müssen sie alle arbeiten und produzieren
das tun sie auch
gleichzeitig haben wir erlebt
eine globalisierung
jeglichen wirtschaftens heutzutage ist
der anteil der deutschen
an der weltwirtschaft doppelt so hoch
wer damals war
und das gilt ganz besonders für die
finanzmärkte der ist viele mann ist hoch
wer damals war und ist praktisch
und beaufsichtigte
schmidt sieht man kann man kann sagen
sie war einer der erfinder des euros das
geht weit zurück in die 70er jahre mit
der währungs schlange mit dem er also
all den vorläufern des euros aber diese
vorläufer hatten alle den gleichen
grundgedanken die die einzelne währung
europas müssen verschweißt verkettet
werden so dass daraus eine einzige
währung entstehen kann haben sie damals
als sie mit mit mitriss malerisches
gardist angekurbelt haben über diese
dinge haben sie das voraussehen können
was was aus ihrem traum wird werden
würde
es waren keine träume
man was das voraussehen angeht prognosen
sind immer schwierig insbesondere wenn
es sich um die zukunft sein und
ich muss einmal zum gegenwärtigen status
des autos etwas sagen
wenn wir statt des euros die d mark noch
hätten da wäre die demagin zwischen
durch die decke dieser kirche
aufgewertet worden
sie haben recht was griechenland angeht
aber man muss ganz deutlich erkennen
dass der euro heute
was seinen außenwert angeht stabiler ist
als die d mark in den letzten zehn
jahren airbus bestellt
und was den bienen wird an den die
sogenannte inflationsrate ist es
ebenfalls stabile als die zehn letzten
jahre der dema das heißt abgesehen von
griechenland und anderen rand erscheinen
ist der euro eine ganz stabile werden
und herr trittin
und herr draghi
sind mit recht hoch zu loben sie haben
sich über manche verträge etwas
hinweggesetzt das muss man in diesen
zeiten
wir sind dabei durch und durch zum ende
durchzubringen
manchmal aus model ist mogeln gewordenen
er
wandel bedeutet auch dass man nicht alle
regierungsabkommen einhält
dort sind auch dass man international
ratifizierte verträge verletzt dass es
zwangsläufig
es gibt dafür beispiele innerhalb
deutschlands in einer großen krise kommt
man nicht auf die verfassung
ich bin weiß gott ein anhänger des
rechtsstaats
aber zum beispiel während der hamburger
flutkatastrophe haben wir nicht in die
verfassung druckt
und so ist es einander geld krise genau
so und so ist das in einer rezession
auch so keine revolution richtet sich
nach der verfassung wir sind im vorabend
der möglichkeit einer revolution in
europa
was wollen sie eine revolution
herz weiß ich selber nicht
aber ich spüre dass wir uns in einer
unsicherheits situation beschäftigen
befassen und dass die mehrheit der
öffentlichen meinung von spanien und
italien bis nach finnland und
einschließlich deutschlands dass die
mehrheit der öffentlichen meinung das
vertrauen in die europäische vereinigung
etwas abgebaut hat und dass dieser
prozess des vertrauensverlustes noch
nicht zu ende ist vielleicht sind wir in
fünf jahren wieder auf dem aufsteigenden
ast ich möchte das wünschen ich möchte
dazu beitragen aber dass europa im
augenblick nicht gerade die nummer eins
in der beliebtheitsskala der deutschen
ist ist offensichtlich
dies erfordert ein widerwort aus
regierungsamtlichen munde naja gut als
mitglied der bundesregierung kann ich
nicht so reden
über
rechts einhalten von verträgen und
grenzen der verfassung wie man das kann
wenn man helmut schmidt ich habe gehofft
die börsen ergebnis sage ich mit respekt
aber es muss klar sein
es ist doch so wir lernen ja also wenn
wir das beispiel der hamburger
flutkatastrophe nehmen
und jedermann hat einen großen respekt
vor der leistung des damaligen hamburger
innensenator sehen was wir davon noch
was weiß ich war bin alt genug um noch
eine erinnerung zu haben damals gewann
eine solche erfahrung macht dann bringt
dann dann zieht man hinterher auch als
rechtsstaat als verfassungsstaat die
konsequenzen daraus das haben wir
übrigens geschaffen also insofern
wenn unvorhergesehene situationen
eintreten dann kann man in der tat auch
dann gibt es ja auch das kann auch ich
muss ja wieder am montag muss sich mit
herrn voßkuhle beim europäischen
gerichtshof diskutieren weil wenn der wo
liest was ich hier sage also ich bin
schon vorsichtig nicht so
jetzt aber ich dachte sie würden helmut
schmidt vehement widersprechen als der
über
verfassungs flexibilisierung und so
gerade wir versuchen wir wird versuchen
ja das ist ja die aufgabe die den rahmen
des der gegebenen rechtsordnung die
probleme zu lösen
und wenn man dazu nicht in der lage ist
dann kommen revolution zustand der hat
gerade gesagt er fürchte dass eine
revolution
und das ist der fall wurde an die
rechtsordnung nicht mehr ausreicht so
ist es in der in der geschichte in der
politischen und verfassungsgerichte
geregelt aber sie können nicht sie
können nicht verlangen dass ein
regierungsmitglied nun gerade die
revolution vorbereitet jedenfalls selbst
wenn das tod wird das nicht öffentlich
sagen sonst ist eine rarität
deswegen müssen wir aber gelegentlich
vorschläge machen wie über die
rechtsordnung anpassen euro
einschließlich unserer nationalen
verfassung und das grundgesetz ist ja
natürlich wenn die grand darüber haben
wir ja oft diskutiert wenn wir brauchen
in europa institutionelle fortschritte
ich teile übrigens nicht die meinung
haben uns mit wenn ich das sagen darf
dass die bevölkerung das dass europa so
unbeliebt sei natürlich machen sich die
menschen sorgen aber wir können auch mit
in dem die menschen sich mehr sorgen
machen werden sie sich auch der
bedeutung etwas wissen um das sie sich
sorgen machen besser bewusst wir haben
jetzt zum ersten mal in aktuellen
umfragen eine meinung einem eine
mehrheit gehabt die gesagt hat
griechenland sollte im euro gehalten
werden das war zweieinhalb jahre lang
anders wir müssen also nicht dass die
bevölkerung ist nicht unser problem
dass das problem das ist in der
demokratie nie so
der sich nur die arroganz der die auf
dem podium sitzen dass sie glauben das
volk sein das problem das problem sehen
immer nur die regierenden nächstes 9
sonst funktioniert die demokratie doch
das volk stimmt ab und so hat ist das
tut sie auch zwei ist demokratie wir
müssen unsere wir müssen die kraft
aufbringen das ist die wirkliche aufgabe
derjenigen die sich um politische
verantwortung bemüht die veränderungen
rechtzeitig zustande zu bringen wir
brauchen in europa vertragliche
veränderungen und möglicherweise kommen
wir auch eingrenzen wurde an unser
grundgesetz er angepasst werden muss an
diese europäische entwicklung obwohl
wir im grundgesetz
1949 schon formuliert haben als zahl als
ziel
in der präambel des grundgesetzes steht
es ja das deutsche volk vom willen
beseelt als gleichberechtigtes glied in
einem vereinten europa dem frieden der
welt zu dienen also damals haben die
noch ein bisschen mehr gewusst und
manchmal tun wir ja inzwischen so als
wäre das alles
wäre das alles gar nicht erlaubt nein in
der globalisierung müssen wir wenn wir
unsere verantwortung für die zukunft
gerecht werden neue formen finden um das
was wir unter unter rechtsstaatlichkeit
und demokratie auch unter der
verwirklichung von menschenrechten nicht
nur dem rechtlichen auch im sozialen
sinne der nachhaltigkeit zu
verwirklichen das geht nicht mehr in den
alten gewohnheiten des nationalstaats
alleine dass die jahrhunderte sind
vorüber im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
brauchen wir andere formen von global
governance dazu für global auch glaube
governance gesagt das internet an wie es
die welt verändert haben und schmid hat
gerade von den finanzmärkten und der
globalisierung geredet wenn wir dann ob
das 21 jahrhundert vorbereiten wollen
und es nicht den revolutionen oder sind
katastrophen überlassen müssen wir ein
bisschen mehr veränderungen betreiben
und bereit sein als wir uns gelegentlich
in unseren debatten an daten
ich finde dass mal wieder diesen den
zusammenhang zum euro und den
zusammenhang zwischen euro und
institutionen herstellen der euro
basiert die auf eine reihe von
glaubenssätzen
und lass mir zu einer metapher greifen
da wurden plötzlich glaube ich am anfang
12 lokomotiven also zwölf länder
zusammen gekoppelt die mussten im euro
jeder im selben tempo in die selbe
richtung fahren die dürften sich über
heizen
sonst würde dieser zug entgleisen rsn
fast entgleist weil sich die einzelnen
lokomotivführer nicht an die regeln
gehalten haben also geringe defizite
geringe schulden
geringeren platz internen inflationsrate
und so weiter das heißt den glauben dem
wir in den institutionen des euro ist
die verträge
maastricht all die dinge die regeln
auferlegt haben und grenzen auferlegt
haben haben nicht funktioniert woher
nehmen sie jetzt schon den glauben dass
wir es oft diese
angeknackste diskussion noch stärker
aktion setzen können die weiter
entziehen ali sieren und helmut schmidt
hat gesagt die revolution liegt in der
luft das möchte ich mal von beiden
irgendwie jetzt zusammen gepasst kriegen
also zieht schmidt was die revolution
mit schmidt ist bei uns derzeit
redaktion für evolution zuständig
ich bin nicht für die revolution
zuständig ich bin für den rechtsstaat
zuständig aber ich spüre die möglichkeit
vom revolutionären veränderungen auf der
welt
china ist gegenwärtig in einer tiefen
innenpolitischen krise
amerika hat seine krise gerade eben
scheinbar überwunden aber nur dem
anschein nach die ökonomischen krisen
amerika es nach wie vor die gleiche die
sie am tag vor der wahl war
den vertrauensverlust gegenüber der
europäischen idee von der die rede war
ist eine tatsache und die wird nicht von
heute auf morgen
beseitigt werden
eine der fehler ist die übertreibung
rechtsstaatlicher vor schluss der
vertrag von maastricht enthält schwere
lippen und es fällt manchen details die
überflüssig war er enthielt zum beispiel
die einladung an jedermann in europa er
möge doch bitte der europäischen
gemeinschaft beitreten der war damals
zwölf mitgliedstaaten heute sind wir 27
stellen sie sich die deutsche bank oder
siemens oder mrn mit 27
gleichberechtigten vorstandsmitgliedern
vor dann haben sie die europäische
kommission erfüllen lächeln zu stimmen
aus dem handel noch kann barroso als
präsidentin und dann haben sie außerdem
noch einen europäischen präsidenten und
einen präsenten der europäischen
gemeinsame außen und sicherheitspolitik
die sind wirklichkeit gar nicht gibt das
als die regierenden neigen dazu ihre
eigene ohnmacht zu kaschieren durch
immer neue bestimmung herr schäuble hat
vorhin g g 20 und g 20 hatte es vor dem
jahr 2008 überhaupt nicht gegeben es war
eine augenblick schöpfung am ende des
jahres 2008 der eine reihe tüftler
richtig dass beschlüsse gefasst und wenn
sie genau hingucken ist von diesen
beschlüssen in wirklichkeit dass es vier
jahre her heute fast nichts
verwirklicht worden mit der ganz großen
ausnahme dass alle staaten
geld gedruckt haben und dass alle
zentralbanken geld gedruckt haben wir
haben die welt bewahrt vor einer
weltrezession vor aller welt
depression aber die übrigen bestimmungen
sind praktisch papier geblieben und man
muss sich mühe geben sich an sie zu
verändern nehmen sie als beispiel
alles das was die g 20 jahre 2008
beschlossen hat an überwachung von
investmentfonds von der volcker rule ist
heute keine rede mehr alles das ist
abgesunken und das heißt die
investmentbanken
spielen wieder genauso verrückt
wie sie 2007 verrückt gespielt hatten
und wie sie 2006 und 2005 verrückt
gespielt hatten eine der wichtigsten
lehren aus der krise des jahres 2008 und
2009 ist bisher nicht erzogen worden und
damit sind zusammen euro der
finanzminister sagte
das klasse ist mehr als halb voll
und sie reden von revolutionen
vorrevolutionären zu stellen die sich
wahrscheinlich darauf beziehen dass in
all diesen ländern vor allem in den
krisenländern großer widerstand 6 gegen
die reformen die sehr schmerzhafte
markt und mikroökonomischen form die
absolut unabdingbar sind damit der euro
nicht zusammenbricht
was wie
wir raten sie oder wie sehen sie das was
ist stärker die vernunft oder die
revolution ich möchte eigentlich nicht
in der hamburger
michaeliskirche als proponent der
revolution dargestellt werden das tun
sie und dann das muss ich als widerstand
als er hat seine schwere überzeugung
beiseite schieben
ich möchte mich auch nicht beteiligen an
der institutionellen debatte ich will
mein kleines beispiel erzählen
irgendwann in den 70er jahren
mitte der 70er jahre
war italien in einer akuten
zahlungsbilanzkrise
und die brauchten frisches geld
wir haben keine institution begründet
keinen vertrag gemacht
sondern wir haben ihnen das geld ist für
eine einstellige milliarden größeres war
damals ein riesenberg
und wir haben es gegeben als kredit der
bundesbank an die banca d'italia und
weil es die bundesbank war hat sie das
gold der italiener als pfand genommen
die italiener haben aber zurückgezahlt
sie haben ihr gold wieder gekriegt und
alles war in butter und die institution
haben wir nicht gebraucht das ganze hat
die europäische
gemeinschaft nicht berührt man könnte
wenn wir noch im jahre 2004 wehren oder
im jahre 2008 wären dann könnte man die
gegenwärtige krise auch ohne die
institutionen zu benutzen
hinkriegen
das haben wir nicht getan das haben wir
uns auf dieses institutionen verlassen
und nun sind wir einigermaßen verlassen
das heißt aber doch nicht dass wir
deswegen den pessimismus uns ergeben
müssen das wort modeling suite
lässt ja offen den guten ausgang der
sache und denn jeder der einzelnen
modeling
schritt
vernünftig
angelegt ist dann kommen wir heute in 2
34 jahren die phönix aus der asche und
fragen uns was war eigentlich los was
war eigentlich los im jahre
2019 148
das waren dramatisch dass schumann plant
am
marshall plan kann 48 die bananen kann
und die apfelsinen kann
und plötzlich war alles in butter und
heute fragen wir uns machbar halten dich
durch es ist durchaus wahrscheinlich
dass die europäer sich rausflogen
andererseits müssen die europäer wissen
dass die chinesen
und die inder und die brasilianer dass
sie alle eine ähnliche entwicklung
durchmachen wie vor 150 jahren die
japaner sie gemacht haben nach der messe
essen und der enorme aufschwung chinas
wird die ganze welt verändern und europa
bleibt relativ klein
klein
das durchschnittsalter der europäer ist
zu meinen lebzeiten um mehr als zehn
jahre
gewachsen die durchschnittliche
lebenserwartung eines neugeborenen ist
um mehr als zehn jahre gewachsen in der
zeit in der alle hier in der halle das
miterlebt es ist aber in unser
bewusstsein ich ein die leute nach wie
vor mit 62 in rente gehen und
möglicherweise in griechenland mit 58
das mag so sein aber die alten werden
immer älter immer hält und wir werden
uns daran gewöhnen müssen dass wir
länger arbeiten und das ist ein teil
dieser quasi revolutionären
situationen der sich die völker befinden
es fällt auch den franzosen
außerordentlich schwer von der 35
stunden woche weg zu gehen aber
natürlich ist dummes zeug die aber da 35
stunden in der woche zum zu beschränken
sie geben mir das stichwort wenn man mit
einem einzigen bild dann einzige
statistischen bild die euro krise
erklären möchte denn würde man die
kurven aufzeichnen der lohnstückkosten
also dieses dieser werte die
produktivität und arbeitskosten ernst
ins verhältnis bringen und da sieht man
auch nichts dramatisches bild der
divergenz in einem system das eigentlich
konvergenz
erzeugen sollte in der ersten dekade des
euros gehen die deutschen
lohnstückkosten um 7 prozent hoch die
französischen um 25 die italienischen 35
und die griechischen 42 da hat man das
mit dem einen bild die ganze euro krise
erklärt die deutschen sind haben
hausaufgaben gemacht sind
wettbewerbsfähig gegeben haben dadurch
gewaltige exportüberschüsse angesammelt
und die anleihen sind hat ihre
wettbewerbsfähigkeit verloren das heißt
dass jetzt kann man aber zwei wege gehen
man kann sagen die deutschen sollen
jetzt ein bisschen mehr ausgeben mehr
konsumieren weniger sparen sich mehr
leisten die löhne nach oben treiben oder
die anderen sollen so werden die
deutschen hätten als die beiden herren
herr minister wenn sie das bild nehmen
wir nennen das
das krokodil also auseinander geht es
geht inzwischen
geht es wieder zusammen
das heißt ja das ist doch eine gute
botschaft wir haben jetzt schon vorweg
genommen
wir haben wir haben zugegeben wir wissen
dass das das so war trainer hat uns das
in jeder sitzung die schau bilder
gezeigt und inzwischen gehen die
lohnstückkosten in spanien zurück in
irland sind sie deutlich gesungen in
griechenland man glaubt es kaum sind sie
erheblich gesunken in deutschland
steigen sie moderat an das ist
vertretbar dafür werde ich dann in
deutschland kritisiert dass wir nicht
konsequent genug unsere außenpolitik
betreiben dann sage ich immer ich muss
aber auch ich muss noch im kopf haben
was sich außerhalb deutschlands sage
nämlich dort muss ich sagen wir achten
auch darauf dass die im balances die
ungleichgewichte nicht immer größer
werden und wenn wir das dann moderat tut
wir können also dieses problem im
übrigen nicht dadurch lösen dass die
deutschen jetzt inflationieren denn dann
verliert man einen schuldenschnitt
widersprechen langsam das
was haben uns mit sagen wenn ich will
nur noch darauf hinweisen wenn wir nicht
im wesentlichen das problem in europa
dadurch lösen dass die anderen
wettbewerbsfähiger werden und nicht dass
wir
produktivitäts zurückgehen dann werden
wir nämlich im globalen wettbewerb als
europäer alle miteinander verlieren und
deswegen müssen wir das im wesentlichen
dadurch schließen dass die anderen
besser werden absolut richtig
aber helmut schmidt wird ihm deshalb
widersprochen weil ich war mir diese
debatten in einer redaktionskonferenz
führen und jetzt von hermann schmid
sagen wir ihr das absolut richtige was
sie verkümmern korrigieren wird ich hab
sie akustisch nicht verstanden
das ist auch
eine art indem wir diskutieren
ich habe erst gesagt die anderen müssen
besser werden sie müssen ihre lohnkosten
senken sie müssen kompetitiver werden
dagegen steht das wort das man sagt
wieso dann wir sind ja auch teil des
problems
wir haben eben zu waren ihm zu tüchtig
wir haben zu viel exportiert und wir
haben denen die märkte damen dadurch
weggenommen
ich bin der meinung dass
sowie die welt nun mal beschaffen ist
eigentlich alle länder sich bemühen
müssen ihre außen wirtschaftliche bilanz
im gleichgewicht zu halten ausfuhren und
einfuhren im gleichgewicht zu halten
dass viele länder das nicht können ist
offensichtlich
andererseits
ist es ganz ungewiss und in der
weltgeschichte bisher kaum vorgekommen
dass zwei länder
riesenhafte
überschüsse erzielen nämlich china und
deutschland
und bei den deutschen spielt übrigens
ein sonderthema
eine große rolle von der wir noch eines
tages schwere nackenschläge erwarten
könnten das ist der export von
kriegswaffen
deutschland ist der drittgrößte
exporteur von kriegs flugzeugen von
kriegsschiffen und von maschinen disco
maschinengewehren und anderen
kanonen das heißt mindestens dieser teil
ist aus aussenpolitischen und aus
sicherheitspolitischen gründen allein
von höchst zweifelhaft wieso soll
ausgerechnet dieses land in der mitte
europas der drittgrößte waffenexporteur
der ganzen welt sein aber darüber hinaus
ist
der deutsche überschuss
der exporte über die importe hat heute
an die größenordnung von über fünf
prozent des
bruttosozialprodukts das ist doppelt so
viel wie zur zeit entschieden
das ist absolut ungesund und die
deutschen haben da nichts davon wenn sie
kriegen papier für waren wir exportieren
waren und sind kriegen dafür papier das
sie drauf
sonst so viele dollars und wir schulden
uns in wirklichkeit die wohltat von mehr
importen okay das heißt praktisch
das heißt praktisch wir müssen die löhne
hier schneller wachsen lassen wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass die deutschen weniger
sparen und mehr ausgeben oder vielleicht
dass sie nicht ganz so hart arbeiten
vielleicht in ein bisschen mehr geld
ausgeben ich würde die sprache nicht
unbedingt senden die deutschen sind ein
volk von sparern das bleibt so
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger hart
arbeiten und jedenfalls sich bewusst
sein dass ein
exportüberschuss von fünf prozent des
sozialprodukts ein verstoß ist gegen die
vernunft irgendwie welt ökonomische
vernunft
ist das große sünde also zunächst einmal
muss ich doch darauf hinweisen
sie haben mich ich habe gesagt wir
müssen die ungleichgewichte in europa
so lösen dass wir das die anderen den
größeren teil durch verbesserung der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit leisten müssen und
wie er den kleineren teil mit mit
anpassung mit einem anstieg der
lohnstückkosten der größere teil muss
präsident andere und das will ich doch
mit dem argument unterlegen die eurozone
als ganzes
ist nun fast vorbildlich sie hat nämlich
ein völlig ins gleichgewicht sie hat ein
völlig jetzt gleichgewicht ohne
deutschen überschuss hätte die eurozone
ein deutliches 1 eine 3 1 deutlich
negativ bilanz insofern müssen wir ein
bisschen global unterscheiden nehmen wir
deutschland mein sonst kommen wir auch
noch die frage ist es mit hamburg oder
wie ist das mit mecklenburg vorpommern
in deutschland oder baden württemberg
konnten wir jetzt die ungleichgewichte
auch korrigieren indem wir eine grün
rote landesregierung haben geht schon
bergab aber ist eine andere geschichte
nein wenn wir europa als ganzes nehmen
sind wir ausgeglichen sind wir
ausgeglichen im augenblick lebt europa
ein stück war dabei und damit ich doch
die zweite bemerkung auch machen solange
wir in deutschland und in europa
übrigens auch ein sozial niveau
erwarten einen sozial leistungsniveau
europa hat im vergleich zu allen anderen
teilen der welt ein sehr viel höhere
sozialquote das ist auch richtig
kritisieren es gar nicht aber vor dem
hintergrund der ganz eigenen demographie
helmut schmidt beschrieben hat die
europa hat würde ich nun dringender
verraten davon abraten den leuten zu
haben das sollten wir jetzt weniger
arbeiten und mehr verbrauchen und damit
würden wir in der in der globalisierten
welt unsere zukunftschancen besser
wahrnehmen ich glaube auch nicht dass
helmut schmidt so verstanden werden bin
ich jedenfalls gerade dazu dass wir uns
darüber im klaren sind europa muss
sich bewusst sein europa insgesamt
dass die herausforderungen in der welt
der globalisierung so sind dass wir
unseren beitrag zu einer globalen
nachhaltigen entwicklung nur leisten
können wenn wir auch wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben und die anforderungen daran sind
unglaublich viel größer als noch vor
zwei oder drei jahrzehnten
ich möchte gleich in diese kerbe hauen
wir reden ja seit jahren gern vom
niedergang unaufhaltsamen niedergang
amerikas
und haben dabei völlig außer augen
gelassen vergessen zwei
zahlenreihen die die mich doch sehr sehr
bedrückt die europa betreffen das
amerikanische bruttoinlandsprodukt
welt der anteil am weltproduktion eben
über 40 jahre 25 26 prozent
dass der eu-27 in den letzten 40 jahren
ist um sage und schreibe zehn punkte
gefallen
zweiter zeitreihe
in dieser zeit in diesen 40 jahren ist
das wachstum der eu-27 dekade um die
karte etwa am halben punkt
abgefallen das fängt an bei 1 3 kann man
noch was
liegt jetzt natürlich bei null aber dass
es krisenbedingt aber selbst vor der
krise was dann von drei kann man noch
was auf eines kann man noch was
abgesunken das ist das ist sozusagen die
da sind sind die nackten zahlen
und deshalb ist meine frage jenseits von
eur
wie
geben wir europa diese dynamik zurück
die europa sind zum wunderkind zum
wirtschaftswunder kind der 70er jahre
gemacht hatte oder wollen wir einfach
auf sehr sehr hohem niveau und ist sehr
gut gehen lassen
wir werden die dynamik die während der
nachkriegszeit in den aufbaujahren
einziger 70 die werden wir in der 1 da
war auch noch aufbauzeit wenn sie die
unterschiede wie wird ein stück
langsamer werden es werden andere in
anderen teilen der welt höhere
wachstumsraten haben müssen
wenn diese welt im 21 jahrhundert sich
an ihren spannungen und ihren
ungleichheiten und ungerechtigkeiten zu
grunde gehen will ich kann denen ich und
wenn es diesen bitte auf wer die
höchsten wachstumsraten hat der wird die
welt der wird nicht nachhaltig sein und
deswegen müssen wir denn sonst sagen
wenn an wenn die wenn die großen region
china
indien brasilien lateinamerika insgesamt
brasilien ist im augenblick fast schon
eher nieder sorgenkind in lateinamerika
afrika
wenn die eine chance haben wollen
aufzuholen
dann müssen sie höhere wachstumsraten
abend als europa aber wir in europa
müssen immerhin so weit sein dass wir
dass wir nicht vor der vor der tour den
beschriebenen zahlenreihe resignieren
gesellschaften können noch ganz schnell
plötzlich in panik geraten wenn sie
nicht mehr wenn sie keine zukunft
vertrauen mehr haben letzten endes ist
es alles eine frage wie eine
gesellschaft auch
zuversicht hat wie es weitergehen wird
denn sonst gerät sie in panik oder in
und oder in irrationale übertreibungen
und wenn wir das stabil halten wollen
müssen wir uns für nachhaltigkeit
einsetzen das können die europäer aber
wir müssen natürlich schon darauf achten
dass wir einigermaßen wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben und deswegen sage ich ja der
größere teil des ihrer ihres ihrer ihre
ihrer schere in der wettbewerbsfähigkeit
und der produktivität in europa muss so
geschlossen werden dass andere
produktiver werden wettbewerbsfähiger
und genau diesen versuch machen war da
sind wir nicht am ende aber die richtung
halte ich für richtig
helmut schmidt
ein letztes wort
im zuge der
wettbewerbsfähigen werden wir von den
radiosendern gedrängt schluss zu machen
ein letztes wort zum thema zuversicht
und europa und wachstum und wieder
aufstieg
ich will vorweg sagen dass ich den
ausführungen von herrn schäuble
weitgehend frei pflicht
was
optimismus und pessimismus angeht ich
bin immer ein skeptiker gewesen aber ich
habe immer an den grundsätzen
festgehalten an den prinzipien fest
gehalten
eine der wichtigsten prinzipien
ist
die fähigkeit zum kompromiss
das ist etwas was in deutschland kaum
begriffen wird eine demokratie die den
kompromiss nicht kann geht unter
und was wir heute in europa notwendig
haben ist die fähigkeit zum kompromiss
kein kompromiss ist ohne fehler viele
fehler addieren sich zu einem plus
letzten endes viele addieren sich zu
einem plus zum schluss so eines lust
hab ich gesagt meine ich auch meine ja
und ich sehe überhaupt keinen grund
dass wir hier allesamt
enthusiasmus eingehen okay war kein gott
meine damen und herren ich habe gott
noch was über mathematik gelernt viele
fehler die er sich zu einem plus ein
brillantes schlusswort von helmut
schmidt eine brilliante veranstaltung
von den beiden und sie verdienen
wie sie mir sicherlich wieder übernehmen
werden eine laute runde applaus
so und dann hätten wir noch zwei die
sich mit dem vertrauen in europa und dem
vertrauen in die wirtschaft beschäftigen
und allein bei den namen möchte man
sogleich glauben dass die ankündigung
eines streitgesprächs dem titel auch
gerecht werden wird rainer brüderle von
der fdp selbst erfahren als
wirtschaftsminister und oskar lafontaine
von den linken für ein halbes jahr war
er finanzminister der schröder-regierung
das sind die beiden diskutanten die sich
mit du an reden und beide weinliebhaber
sind jedoch war es das dann auch schon
mit den gemeinsamkeiten
und mehr will ich gar nicht vorwegnehmen
die beiden sind obwohl sie sich nahe
stehen trotzdem politisch
grundverschieden und trotzdem einfach
etwas ihrer jeweiligen partei geht es im
augenblick nicht besonders gut deswegen
würde ich sie bitten einmal gedanklich
die position und die präferenz zu
tauschen und herr lafontaine mal
angenommen sie wären liberaler wie
würden sie die fdp retten ja ich würde
hier hoch bringen weil ich
will der aktuelle vorsitzende und der
künftige wahrscheinlich auch ja weil ich
zum beispiel und das war ich ja prödl
das heißt jetzt nicht nur konkrete ri
ist sehr starke hand von den euro
liberalismus der also in einem punkt
meine politischen theorien wenn du so
fielen immer wieder unterstützt der
ordoliberalismus also die freiburger
schule sie wollten wirtschaftliche macht
verhindern sie wollten nach dem kriege
eine wird eine wirkliche demokratie und
sie wollten daher wirtschaftliche macht
verhindern ich übersetze das jetzt mal
auf die aktualität ich habe das ein
brüder auch mal gesagt aber hört ja
nicht auf mich deshalb stehen ja da wo
sie stehen
also ich hätte ja bringt doch ein gesetz
ein das eben ab einer bestimmten
bilanzsumme es keine bank mehr geben
darf also mehr als zehn prozent des
sozialproduktes gab es keine so würden
die ordoliberalen sagen keine bank geben
dass also etwa wenn die deutschen banken
mal tauchten die zahl auf
2500 milliarden meint einen höheren
zahlen auf also in der größenordnung
sozialprodukt eine bankbilanz heller
schwachsinn das ist wahnsinn also muss
man sagen höchstens zehn prozent und
noch weniger und das wäre zum beispiel
dann kämen die auch wieder hoch aber die
höheren halt nicht möglich na ja es
kommt ja immer darauf an auf welche
markt ist sich bezieht deutsche bank
kooperiert zum beispiel weltweit ist
unterschied zu in der regionalen
sparkasse die in anderen relevanten
markt aber der grundsatz dass der
wettbewerb des genial steht macht uns
instrument ist dann halte ich für
richtig deshalb will man ja wettbewerb
haben keine monopole der liberalismus
entstanden im kampf gegen adels
vorherrschaft gegen fatalismus die
monopolstrukturen um freiheit zu machen
paulskirche offenburg war stadt haben
aber fest die symbole dieser
freiheitsbewegung die dabei ist von
dieser grundgedanke habe ich unverändert
für entscheidend und ist auch mal einen
fehler meiner partei wenn ich die
hinzufügen darf zu der von lafontaine
ist bei dem brot und butter themen zu
konzentrieren
das sind für mich bürgerrechte das für
mich bildungspolitik und soziale
marktwirtschaft das heißt dass kein
ungezügelten kapitalismus sondern es
eine rahmengesetzgebung und der sich die
wirtschaft entfaltet das ist
ordnungspolitik neoliberal ist leider zu
einem schimpfwort geworden früher war
neoliberal die position gegen die nazi
herrschaft und der ansatz der sozialen
marktwirtschaft nach dem krieg also
müller eugen röcke gründungsvater dieses
konzeptes haben sich als neoliberale
verstanden gegenüber der zeit zuvor
heute ist es leider bisschen misskredit
geraten aber gemeint ist wirklich ein
rahmen zu setzen menschen entfaltung und
chancen eigenverantwortung haben können
chance ein risiko und da müssen wir
wieder die balance auch in der
finanzwelt stärker schaffen sie ihre
chance risiko ja ich will das thema
nicht vertiefen aber ich möchte bringe
ich bin davon überzeugt wenn man nicht
an die an banken der größenordnung der
deutschen bank herangeht und sie
deutlich verkleinert ist nach meinem
verständnis
demokratische entscheidung überhaupt
nicht mehr möglich denn wir sehen dass
er jetzt europaweit die parlamente
rennen der bankenwelt hinterher und auch
der deutsche bundestag und müssen einen
schirm nach dem anderen und ein
versprechen an dem anderen kassieren man
kann also vereinfacht sagen nicht die
das parlament bestimmt sondern die
bankenwelt bestimmt und das ist ja ein
völlig ungesunder zustand und dann laut
und liberaler würde sofort sagen dieses
system müssen wir sofort grundsätzlich
reformieren da überlagern sich zwei
dinge wir haben eine globalisierung
da muss man sehen weltweit ist die
stellung der deutschen bank im regen der
größenordnung schwächer als von 20-25
jahre sie relativ schwächer geworden
dabei von der größenordnung her von den
umsätzen her und ist uralt der streit
auch unter ökonomen trend bankensystem
trentmann klassische bank funktion von
investment banking oder
universalbankensystem
deutschland hatte eigentlich immer das
universalbankensystem von dem ich
persönlich glaube dass nach wie vor in
sich stabiler ist weil er stärker
ausgleichen kann was haben die
amerikaner der krise gemacht sie haben
ihr investmentbank goldmann sachs und
anderen einer vollbanklizenz gegeben um
sie damit ein stück zu stabilisieren
entscheidend ist dass man die
spielregeln verändern müssen und da mal
ein stück fortschritt aber noch nicht
genügend wir haben bestimmte geschäfte
verboten ungedeckte leerverkäufe wir
haben die bilanzrelationen verschärft
wir brauchen auch in europäischer ebene
der preis hilft ja nichts wenn wir in
deutschland unsere bank war sie
atomisieren und ringsum europa eine ganz
andere entwicklung ist jetzt sind heute
europäische markt da liegt ein teil der
schwierigkeiten die briten denken gar
nicht daran die regel wie wir es in
kontinentaleuropa da sind wir eher mit
der franzose auf einen weg als mit dem
briten mit zu übernehmen
nun ist unser haupt konkurrenz platz für
frankfurt deshalb ist der ansatz man
muss es breiter fassen wir sind in der
globalen wirtschaft und könne nicht
allein nur mit nationalen regeln die
probleme mit der der körper die
kanzlerkandidat peer steinbrück ein
papier vorgelegt in denen er auch die
zerschlagung von banken fordert die
aufspaltung und wieder die einführung
des trennbankensystems
wie deuten sie das ist das für sie eine
absage an ein rot gelb an einer sozial
liberale koalition nach der wahl oder
glauben sie nicht an die ernsthaftigkeit
viele standort forscht ich glaube ist er
eine ansage aber die liegen seiner
partei damit er die partei hinter sich
kriegt denn mit position nicht im
mainstream der spd in vielen dingen die
vergangenheit hat doch ganz anders
gehandelt er hat ihr das gemacht als
minister westlotto westphal west tv
zweistelliger milliarden-betrag
verbrannt die landesbank habe etwa 130
milliarden verbrannt bisher steuerzahler
gehen sie der staatsbank sicher schon
100 prozent in staatsbesitz dabei und er
hat ja deregulieren die hedge fonds
zugelassen er hat ja diese
veränderungsprozesse selbst gemacht
deshalb finde ich sehr merkwürdig dass
er jetzt vom paulus zum saulus geworden
ist und genau weiß wie es nicht geht
nach dem was vorher genau falsch zu
glauben nicht der anderen ich glaube
dass ist auch ein stück taktik ist wie
der politik dabei und das ist nicht sein
kernanliegen ist er muss schauen dass er
die spd hinter sich bringt so das sonst
als kanzlerkandidat der chance haben
dabei und das wird im linken flügel spd
sicherlich anders gesehen als peer
steinbrück also noch
bundesfinanzminister war jetzt müssen
wir unser kleines gedankenexperiment
noch zu ende bringen wir wissen die was
kann der familie in die fdp retten würde